[Musique]
passer par exemple au solide au savon
solide dans la salle de bain si on prend
des exemples au niveau de la cuisine ça
va être déjà faire le tri sélectif donc
ça c'est quand même important tout le
monde malheureusement ne fait pas encore
de tresseractif peut-être se mettre au
compostage pour ceux qui ont un jardin
ça peut représenter jusqu'à 30% de
déchets en moins des déchets organiques
[Musique]
la cuisine évidemment la cuisine parce
que c'est là où on va on va parfois
faire aussi du gaspillage alimentaire on
sait que ça peut représenter jusqu'à 100
euros par foyer de nourriture jetée et
parfois de la nourriture déjà emballée
[Musique]
alors le but de cet appartement et de
cette exposition n'est pas de faire zéro
déchet nous on veut pas culpabiliser non
plus le public l'idée c'est d'avoir une
démarche qui va faire qu'on va réduire
ses déchets il y a des tas de petits
gestes et émis bout à bout vont faire
que à la fin de l'année ça sera une
quantité conséquente de déchets qui
pourront être réduite
[Musique]